brooks trying to go for that draw okay  yum says no  um you can trade but on my terms and  suddenly how are you stopping that black  pawn  you don't need to david the clock is  doing it for you  three seconds three seconds bishop is  going to go and cover that square yeah  i think it's a draw on the board as well  the white bishop will just stop this  pawn  and uh yeah the white king will come  across and pick it off  it's a draw on the board but one second  left for a level ironian  is not enough no this is mission  impossible absolutely no way  dead drawn position but liam was going  to win on time  and levon he's pre-moving everything  he's down to less than one second  that's impressive pre-move gosh  is he still going oh my god he's still  going but the time does eventually run  out  wow can you guys believe it that is the  first time we've seen a player actually  lose  on time in the armageddon and this means  that liam le  is ready for his first